tucked away in the shadows of blime mana
are a ton of creepy hidden details
secret ghosts and haunting of hill house
easter eggs you probably didn't notice
on your first viewing
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing the spookiest things
you missed in the haunting of bly manor
spoilers ahead of course so take care
one of the most rewarding parts of
rewatching the haunting anthology series
is discovering all the clues laid out in
the early episodes to the big twists and
reveals at the end of each season
when dany arrives in london she stops to
look at a map
right in front of a huge clock or
chronograph display there are cogs and
stopwatches nestled within the larger
timepiece
hinting towards the importance of time
and the various time loops within the
story that's about to be told
and it also foreshadows the countdown or
ticking clock that hangs over dany after
she lets viola possess her in the finale
and the eternal fate that awaits her as
the lady of the lake
another detail foreshadowing the final
destination of many of blimey's
characters is in the small painting in
dany's room at the hostel
there are three famous world landmarks
in the picture the eiffel tower
big ben and the statue of liberty big
ben is of course in london where dany's
haunted journey begins
and the statue of liberty points to how
in the finale danny and jaime leave
england and go traveling in america
where they settle down together
as for the eiffel tower that's a pointer
to dany and jamie visiting owen in paris
where he opens up the restaurant he's
always dreamed about
and dany's room number at the hostel 217
pays homage to stephen king's the
shining
the number is the same as a haunted room
in the novel
and fittingly dany continues to be
haunted by the ghost of her ex-fiance in
that room
of course haunting creator mike flanagan
also wrote and directed dr
sleep the sequel to stanley kubrick's
movie of the shining
another shining reference pops up later
in the children's classroom at bly manor
look
very closely at miss jaisal's desk where
there are a handful of scrabble tiles
that spell out the word red rum
red rum is a creepy message that
appeared in both the shining and dr
sleep and which
spells murder backwards this easter egg
foreshadows how peter quint will later
kill rebecca when he takes possession of
her body and drowns her in the lake
a particularly spooky hill house easter
egg in flora's room
is a smiley face on top of a chest of
drawers this is a nod to mr smiley who
turns out to be the abusive foster
father of one of theo's clients as well
as a terrifying apparition that appeared
to theo one night
what's especially interesting about this
is that the smiley face is positioned
above flora's lady of the lake doll
which lies beneath the cabinet
in hill house the little girl explained
to theo that mr smiley lived below the
house
similar to mr smiley the lady of the
lake is a malevolent
monster who emerges from below the
surface and it's why flora insists that
dany leave the ghostly doll where it is
put her back she stays
there another night just after dany
tucks flora into bed she accidentally
knocks into the lady of the lake doll
which has made a sudden appearance in
the middle of the floor
this little incident foreshadows how
dany will stumble into viola's path at
the end of the eighth episode
and when dany then invites viola into
her body
watch the scene very closely because you
can see how the colour of one of dany's
eyes changes from blue to brown
prior to this both dany's eyes were blue
but from this point on
she has one blue and one brown eye a
mark of the beast now living in her body
the same thing happens to miles in the
seventh episode when he lets peter take
over
that's you that's me josh
miles collapses but when he wakes up you
can see how this eye has gone from blue
to brown
and it also happens to rebecca when
peter takes possession of her
because rebecca has brown eyes to begin
with in her case the eye
changes to blue the drawing with the
words come home that flora sends to
miles at boarding school
calling him back to bly manor is a sly
call back to hill house and how olivia
crane both in life and death
told her children to do just that when i
flashed the porch light twice time to
come home
come home my love come home now was also
a message that theo uncovered underneath
the wallpaper at hill house
there's a deep cut reference to hill
house when peter gives miles his dad's
old lighter and says
just don't burn the house down please
this is a nod to how luke
actor oliver jackson cohen's character
in hill house tried to burn the place
down with a lighter
and you can spot an easter egg to the
bowler hat ghost which haunted luke and
hill house in the scene where dany is
waiting to be picked up by
owen right next to her is a hat shop
with a number of bowler hats on display
an early clue that peter quinn had been
possessing miles comes when the young
boy presents dany with a bouquet of
roses in the second episode
in the next episode during a flashback
scene we see peter give flora the same
red and white flowers in rebecca
jaisal's presence
and the way that jaime freaks out when
she finds that miles has taken the
flowers
they weren't ready to be caught is a
subtle illusion to how peter took
rebecca's life too
soon and perhaps also to how he killed
mrs gross when he was in control of
miles
as peter quint continues to develop his
relationship with miles he explains
people are like locked rooms they've all
got different locks and you've got to
guess the shape of their key
and the different methods or unique keys
as peter puts it that he uses to
manipulate those around him such as
rebecca or henry
is reminiscent of how hill house's red
room changes its appearance and function
to appeal to different members of the
crane family and lure them into its trap
you found the key
you want to know the secret we
are the key but it was always the
bedroom
put on different faces so that we'd be
still and quiet
while it digested building on this theme
of keys in blind manor you can spot a
key shaped keyholder by the door in
peter's time loop scenes
there are no keys on it though perhaps a
comment on how peter can't escape from
this time loop that he hates so much
likewise after she dies viola finds
herself locked away in a never-ending
loop
until perdita finds the key to the trunk
that viola set aside for her daughter
and it's no coincidence that jaime's
wearing a chain around her neck with a
padlock attached on the day that dany
brings her the rings there were as a
symbol of their love for each other
the haunting of blind manor also plays
around with the idea from hill house
that the manor is alive
and we can see this in the way the
narrator describes it when dany arrives
and it yawned open to welcome her home
the rooms were larger at night
as though the house itself had a nail
deeply and there's another nod to that
when dany sees flora's dollhouse
open up all by itself the dollhouse is a
replica of blind manor and appears to
have some kind of enchantment as the
dolls inside move around depending on
what the characters and the ghosts they
represent
are in the house dany lives the rest of
her days with differently coloured
eyes and another detail that represents
how she's not entirely human any longer
is the doll that flora gives her when
they say goodbye
are you sure you want to give me this
one must have it it's you
flora regarding dany as a doll means
deep down the little girl understands
something
has changed in the au pair because it
contrasts sharply with what she said to
danny when she first arrived at bly
manor is that me
why no silly you're you it's just a
jolly
when peter reveals his plan for him and
rebecca to permanently take possession
of miles and flora he explains how the
children will be together with their
parents forever
they're going to be tucked away in the
forever house just like we said
it's mum and dad the idea of a forever
house is a throwback to olivia crane's
dream house
this is our forever house although after
she died that effectively became hill
house itself
this is our forever house
nothing bad will ever touch them ever
again
in the sixth episode there's a flashback
scene where dominic wingrave confronts
his wife charlotte about her affair with
his brother henry and we see a note on
the fridge with the word hello written
repeatedly
this is a clever bit of foreshadowing of
the reveal later in the episode that
it's henry who's been responsible for
the silent calls at the manor
because this is exactly what dany says
when she picks up the phone
hello hello hello
there's a cunning clue to henry's
illicit relationship with charlotte in
some of the early
episodes by an advert for a production
of hamlet on a london double-decker bus
both the haunting of blind manor and the
famous shakespeare play
feature men who have relationships with
their brother's wives
and children who lose their fathers also
in both the play and bly manor the dead
father's son
finds himself tormented by a ghost
the haunting of bly manor is the latest
in a very long line of adaptations of
henry james's 19th century novella the
turn of the screw
and creator mike flanagan has said that
the 1961 film version of the story the
innocence was a huge influence on his
show
with danny's surname clayton being a
tribute to that movie's director jack
clayton
another notable homage is the
prayer-like pose of mrs gross's hands in
her opening credits portrait which tips
its hat to the opening credits of the
innocence where the children's new
governess played by deborah carr
clasps her hands in prayer another
seminal moment from the innocence which
blind mana draws on heavily
is a song o willow whaley which pops up
repeatedly throughout each adaptation
[Music]
both fly mana's first episode and the
film begin with the song and several
seconds of complete darkness
with the melancholy lyrics neatly
alluding to the final scene of bly manor
but now alone i lie till my lover
returned to me
when the elder jamie waits to be finally
reunited with dany
oh willow whaley is often used to
indicate when flora and miles are being
possessed by rebecca jessel or peter
quint
the first instance of this is when young
flora is singing it when dany arrives at
the manor
[Music]
what a beautiful song what song flora
responds that way because it was miss
jaisal who was in control and singing
the song in that moment
miles whistles a song after acting
inappropriately around dany
and the music box plays the tune when
miles grabs dany around the neck and
begins to strangle her
[Music]
the tune indicates that peter quint is
in control of miles at each of these
moments
in the netflix show it's shown that
viola is the origin of the mournful song
as we see her sing it when she performs
her nightly walks to her daughter's
bedroom flanagan's series also draws on
several key moments of animal imagery in
the original film
for example the dove miles kills at
school recalls the one whose neck he
broke at home
and kept under his pillow in the movie
then there's a many pictures of
butterflies on flora's walls and the
butterfly hair clip that miles gives
dany and that belong to miss jessel
which recalls the stark image of a
butterfly being eaten in the innocence
and as the painting of a turtle on the
classroom wall which is a call back to
flora's turtle and the innocence and
given the stephen king easter eggs
elsewhere in this scene possibly also an
allusion to the cosmic turtle from
king's macroverse
and of course the tv series also pays
homage to the turn of the screw novella
by henry james through its use of a
prologue with a mysterious storyteller
who name checks the book's title and
their dialogue as also happens in the
original story
and if a child gives the effect another
turn of the screw what do you say to two
in a deviation from the novella though
flanagan's series returns to this
storyteller in an epilogue which reveals
their true identity
the ships on the wallpaper in miles room
and in model form
are a reference to the repeated ship
imagery and maritime metaphors in the
novel
such as the opening chapter where the
children's governess compares bly to a
great drifting ship
lost at sea miles flora and uncle
henry's family name wingrave is a
reference to the name of the family from
another of henry james's short stories
the romance of certain old clothes
which the eighth episode of bly manor
draws upon heavily for its tale of two
sisters their husband and daughter and a
locked trunk filled with dresses and
jewels
and violet and purdes's name willoughby
was the name that henry james gave his
characters in the first version of that
story before he revised it to win grave
when it was republished several years
later
fans of the brilliant eye zombie will
remember actor rahul kohli who plays
cook owen as medical examiner ravi
chakrabarti
and there's a nice nod to his postmortem
performing role in that show in the
final episode of bly manor when the
narrator explains what owen did after
hannah
gross died someone in the village said
that the cook rode with her all the way
to the coroner
and there he insisted on cleaning her
himself and owen's love of puns
including the name of his restaurant a
batter place i mean i've made some good
cakes in my day but this
one is batter echoes eye zombies
endlessly pun-loving ways from its
episode titles to its comic book segues
to its character names
there are of course a stack of hidden
ghosts lurking in the background of bly
manor
and to discover over 80 of them tap here
to watch my full video revealing all the
ones i found
including the soldier the vicar the
plague doctor the doll face ghost
plus the secret hostile ghost there's
also a link in the video description so
did you spot any other interesting
details or hill house easter eggs in bly
manor
leave your comments below and if you
enjoyed this video a thumbs up is hugely
appreciated
tap left for my full blind mana playlist
with a breakdown of the ending and what
that final shot with jamie
really means or tap right for something
else you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers